-Hey, did you see that?
-What?
Yeah, I saw him. Fudo, right?
-Did he have plastic surgery?
-He changed way too much overnight.
-His whole body is different.
-Even his personality changed.
He's done a total 180.
That's seriously Fudo?
Fudo probably did drugs or something.
That creeps me out.
I guess he wanted to change.
He's so distant it's weird.
He's definitely a virgin.
It still won't open?
Maybe it just doesn't work anymore.
You have a nice ass.
Here you go. Take this!
Fudo...
We were just...
Oh, the key.
It's open now.
That's amazing, Fudo.
Thanks.
-Fudo!
-That was so cool!
-Do you want to have lunch together?
-My image of him changed.
I've always wanted to talk to you.
I don't do kids.